kaffee ist quasi eine allzweckwaffe um
technische träume aller art wahr werden
zu lassen
faltbare handys der antrieb von
raumschiffen durch sonnenenergie oder
sogar eine revolution der
batterietechnologie das alles ist
möglich und grafiken kann wirklich viel
es ist das wohl dünnste material der
welt und dabei härter als diamant welche
weiteren absolut krassen eigenschaften
hat kaffee außerdem noch wann setzt sich
endlich als wundermaterial durch oder
ist das alles nur ein riesengroßer hype
das alles und viel mehr jetzt den klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
tausend dank für diesen wirklich mega
spannenden themen vorschlagen das ist
wirklich absolut bahnbrechend über
whatsapp wie er da dabei sein könnte und
noch ein kleines geschenk abstaubt das
erfahrt am ende des videos 300 mal
fester als stahl härter als diamant
flexibler und leitfähiger als kupfer und
zudem das wohl dünnste material der welt
grafen vor zehn jahren hat ein
forschungsteam für die herstellung einer
anatomischen lager grafen den nobelpreis
bekommen und seitdem überschlagen sich
die schlagzeilen zu diesem thema konkret
besteht graffin aus einer einzigen
transparenten schicht aus
kohlenstoffatomen und diese
zweidimensionalität tatsächlich ist ein
kleines wunder denn eigentlich ist alles
mit dem wir zu tun haben dreidimensional
die kohlenstoff atome in graphen sind
ähnlich angeordnet wie bienenwaben und
genau das macht seinen vielen superlativ
eigenschaften aus und so haben wir hier
in clips um jahr schon erst vor kurzem
über den erfolg eines forschungsteams
aus südkorea berichtet die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hatten grafen erstmalig in großen mengen
und zudem noch zu einem vernünftigen
preis hergestellt ihr langfristiges ziel
ist es ein graf enac herzustellen das
innerhalb von nur zwölf minuten voll
geladen ist bei der produktion erinnern
die vielen kleinen grafen bälle ein
wenig an popcorn die grafen welle sollen
in lithium-ionen-akkus sowohl an der
kathode als auch an der anode verwendet
werden und deren ladegeschwindigkeit
enorm erhöhen um das sind wir den teil
zu verstehen braucht man ein bisschen
chemie die kohlenstoffatome im café
sitzen jeweils auf den ecken von
regelmäßig angeordneten sechsecken die
atome wechselwirken ihre elektrischen
felder überlagern sich das verhalten der
elektronen führt dazu dass strom 1,5 mal
besser geleitet wird als es bei kupfer
der fall ist denn die kohlenstoff atome
in graphen sorgen dafür dass sich die
ladungsträger quasi masse los fühlen
doch erst in einigen jahren können wir
wohl darauf hoffen dass solche akkus
indes in industriellem stil hergestellt
werden können doch der erfolg des
forschungsteams der kann auch anderen
industriezweigen von nutzen sein sich
eben ebenfalls mit
akku technologien auseinandersetzen oder
dazu damit zu tun haben zum beispiel
könnten graffin bälle bei der
konstruktion von elektroautos helfen da
sie extrem temperatur stabil sind
samsung wetterte zu recht ein großes
geschäft das unternehmen hat bereits
patente in südkorea und den usa für
seine herstellung der kaffee in belle
angemeldet und es gibt eine weitere
superlative die mit graphen konstruiert
werden könnte kamerasensoren aus graphen
könnte es möglich machen
auch bei der nacht oder anderen
schlechten lichtverhältnissen tolle
bilder zu machen denn sie sehen sie
werden wohl 1000 mal lichtempfindlicher
als die sensoren die derzeit eingesetzt
werden graffin eignet sich auch bestens
für den einsatz in der umwelt
beispielsweise um boden wasser oder luft
aufzubereiten denn es kann weiter
verarbeitet werden zu stark
absorbierende material mit dem sich zum
beispiel ölunfälle bekämpfen ließen ein
bereits entwickelte sie aus kaffee macht
aus meerwasser sauberes trinkwasser auch
im medizinischen bereich könnte graphen
eingesetzt werden ein forschungsteam aus
schottland will eine künstliche haut aus
solarzellen entwickeln die einen roboter
eine roboterhand mit strom versorgt das
café könnte die solarzellen noch
leitfähiger und lichtdurchlässiger
machen aber auch im bereich kleidung
wird kaffee bereits eingesetzt in china
kann beispielsweise hilft es wärme von
warmen körperregionen zu kälteren zu
transportieren zudem reduziert ist die
reibung mit luft und wasser so dass
graphen kleidung also dazu beitragen
könnte sportler agiler und
leistungsfähiger zu machen
doch es gibt einen wermutstropfen so
richtig hat sich graphen bis jetzt nicht
durchgesetzt und das trotz seiner
unvergleichlichen eigenschaften
forschungsteams weltweit sind sich einig
dass das potenzial riesig ist autos und
flugzeuge könnten durch graf in ein viel
geringeres gewicht haben und so deutlich
weniger treibstoff verbrauchen die
smartphone produktion könnte deutlich
preiswerter werden und die
akkutechnologie wie gesagt
revolutioniert werden dort derzeit gibt
es einfach noch zu viele technische
probleme sowohl an der produktion
größerer mengen grafen als auch am preis
dafür scheitert es bislang es gibt nicht
wirklich entsprechende anlagen zur
herstellung und weil die nachfrage nicht
groß genug ist
nicht investiert ein teufelskreis denn
dadurch wird das material natürlich
nicht günstiger experten see und
experten sehen uns an einem punkt wo die
grundlagenforschung zur innovation
übergehen und so kooperation mit der
industrie notwendig sind und die patente
von samsung die lassen ja schon oft
schon seit 2013 läuft eine große graffin
initiative der europäischen union durch
die die erforschung von graphen
finanziell gefördert wird in fünf bis
zehn jahren sollte es dann auch bei uns
im alltag angekommen sein so die
prognose wir können also sehr sehr sehr
gespannt sein
und es dürfte wohl einen extremen
technologischen schub bedeuten hierbei
klicks und dann natürlich alle
neuigkeiten und wenn er kein video dazu
und zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp nur dann
verpasst ihr kein video denn die abo box
auf youtube die ist ja ein bisschen
lückenhaft über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von
mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich und garantiert und zur begrüßung
habe ich noch ein kleines geschenk für
euch einfach hier draufklicken und am
besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks
um social and media abonnieren da
erfahrt ihr das neueste aus der social
media welt aber nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit
dafür auch draufklicken kernfusion haben
wir bald den ersten funktionierenden
reaktor bis dann bleib dran